monsieur je vous souhaite la bienvenue
et vous remercie de votre disponibilité
pour répondre à nos questions nous avons
entamé les travaux de cette commission
d'enquête sur l'identification des
défaillances de fonctionnement au sein
des fédérations françaises de sport du
monde sportif et des organismes de
gouvernance du monde sportif depuis le
20 juillet dernier l'Assemblée nationale
a décidé de sa création à la suite de
très nombreuses révélations publiques de
sportives et sportifs et de diverses
affaires judiciire et entrait à la
gestion de certaines fédérations nos
travaux portent donc sur trois axes les
violences physiques sexuelles ou
psychologiques dans le sport les
discriminations sexuelles et raciales et
les problématiques liées à la
gouvernance financières des organismes
de gouvernance du monde
sportif monsieur vous avez été formé au
FC Nantes vous jouez ensuite à
l'Olympique de Marseille qui remporte la
Ligue de de la Ligue des Champions en
1993 vous avez également joué à la
Juventus de Turin à Chelsea à Valence et
à Valence vous avez été sélectionné 103
fois en équipe de France et en avait été
le capitaine à 54 reprises entre 1989 et
2000 vous participez à la victoire de la
coupe du monde en 98 et à celle du
championnat d'Europe en 2020 vous avez
été entraîneur de l'AS Monaco de la
Juventus de Turin et de l'OM vous êtes
nommé entraîneur sélectionneur de
l'équipe de France en 2012 votre contrat
arrive à expiration en
2026 si le sport en particulier le
football peut-être un formidable vecteur
d'émancipation et de cohésion il a été
marqué ces dernières années par de
nombreuses affaires en lien avec le
champ de cette commission qui ont pu
ternir son image à partir de septembre
2022 comme vous le savez des articles de
presse ont fait état de graves
difficultés de fonctionnement au sein de
la Fédération Française de foot des
faits évoqués portent sur la gouvernance
et le management de la fédération et sur
des faits de harcèlement ou ayant trait
à des violences sexuelles et sexistes au
sein de la FFF comme au Centre national
de football de Clairefontaine un rapport
de de l'IG SR dans un dans une synthèse
et publié en février 2023 fait le
constat d'une gouvernance
défaillante une
entre guillemets directrice générale aux
méthodes brutales et au comportement
jugé
ératique je ferme les guillemets un
j'ouvre les guillemets nouveau président
don les dérivve de comportement sont
incompatibles avec l'exercice de ses
fonctions et l'exigence d'exemplarité
qui leur est attaché je ferme les
guillemets ù je rouvre une politique de
lutte contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles dont dans le réseau fédéral ni
efficace ni
efficiente avez-vous eu connaissance de
ces dysfonctionnement et à quel moment
quel regard portez-vous sur la grave
crise de gouvernance qui qui a touché la
FFF plus généralement pouvez-vous
exposer les faits auxquels s'intéresse
notre commission d'enquête racisme
violence discrimination de toute nature
atteinte à la probité dont vous avez eu
connaissance au cours de votre carrière
dans le football à la fois comme joueur
puis en tant qu'entraîneur quel bilan
tirez-vous de vos observations du milieu
du foot depuis le début de votre
carrière diriez-vous que la situation a
empiré ou c'est au contraire amélioré
concernant les situations de violence de
discrimination et l'évolution de la
gouvernance des instances nationales et
internationales quelle appréciation
portez-vous sur les actions mises en
place pour lutter contre les f fléau et
leur
efficacité je rappelle que cette
audition est ouverte à la presse et
qu'elle est retransmise en direct sur le
site de l'Assemblée nationale avant de
vous laisser la parole et d'entamer nos
échange pendant environ 1 heure je vous
rappelle que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre 1958 rel relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
entendu par une commission d'enquête de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité je vous
invite donc à lever la main droite et à
dire je le jure après avoir activé votre
micro non ah mais c'est pas là je le
jure merci vous avez la parole quand
vous avez terminé vos propos vous fermez
votre micro voilà comme vous avez dit
tout à l'heure pour laisser la parole à
Madame la rapporteur d'cord merci à vous
merci madame la Présidente pour votre
invitation avant de de répondre à vos à
vos questions je voulais juste préciser
le
cadre dans lequel je suis amené à
intervenir en tant que que sélectionneur
de de l'équipe de France A
masculine je suis mené à être
fréquemment au centre technique national
du football à Clairefontaine dans un
lieu bien particulier qui est appelé
entre guillemets pour reprendre
l'expression le le château qui est
complètement isolé par rapport à la au
bâtiment administratif et les
autres secteurs euh de la formation et
préformation qui qui ont lieu à
Clairefontaine donc là c'est pendant la
période de de stage bien évidemment deux
préparations pour les match de l'équipe
de France
A dans ce calendrier qui est fixé bien
évidemment par les instances
internationales à savoir l'UEFA et la
FIFA pour les
différentes
compétition je suis amené à me déplacer
évidemment dans dans ma
fonction pour les matchs que ça soit
dans les stades en France et partout
dans le monde en Europe bien évidemment
et et et dans le monde
euh en plus dans ce calendrier de dates
qui sont fixées avec nous avons chaque
saison sportive cinq euh
rendez-vous fixes pour ces
rassemblements qu'on appelle des plages
internationales pour toutes les équipes
nationales il y a évidemment tous les 2
ans les deux compétitions
internationales à travers le championnat
d'Europe et puis la Coupe du Monde qui
sont attribué à certains pays et où
comme dernièrement nous étions au au au
Qatar comme 4 ans avant en 2018 on était
en Russie ou le champion d'Europe le
prochain qui sera en Allemagne ça c'est
fixé par les les instances international
euh
entre ces dates mon activité de de de
sélectionneur et
essentiellement centralisé sur le suivi
de mes joueurs à travers les matchs
qu'ils peuvent avoir dans leur club que
ce soit français ou étrangers
euh ça m'est arrivé depuis que je suis
sélectionneur à devoir à être sollicité
pour avoir des des
interventions auprès des partenaires
commerciaux de la fédération également
de me déplacer dans les ligues ou les
districts pour
aller au contact au plus près du
football amateur qui
est la chose la plus importante le socle
la base de notre football je sais d'où
je viens je suis passé par là donc c'est
important que j'ai un relationnel avec
eux ajouter à ça j'ai été amené aussi
ponctuellement à intervenir auprès de de
la direction technique nationale en ce
qui concerne la formation de cadrees de
par mon mon vécu et et mon mon
expérience et en conclusion donc de par
ce que je viens de vous dire je ne suis
pas je suis salarié de la Fédération
Française de Football bien évidemment
mais je ne suis pas quotidiennement ni
régulièrement au siège de la Fédération
Française de fotblour j'y viens j'ai un
bureau mais j viens que ponctuellement
lorsque j'ai des euh listes de joueurs à
communiquer ou si je suis sollicité par
par mon Président pour voilà pour avoir
des discussions ou autres mais je ne
suis pas euh au
quotidien
durant une année sportive dans le
fonctionnement classique de la
fédération
on reviendra par la suite sur
différentes questions posées
précédemment mais je voulais vous
interroger aussi sur quel regard
portez-vous sur les graves incidents de
dimanche dernier en marge de la
rencontre sportive entre l'OM et l'OL
plusieurs personnes ont été blessées le
déchaînement de violence se sont dont se
sont rendu coupables une centaines
d'individus à conduit à l'annuation du
match qu'en pensez-vous avez-vous des
commentaires
ce sont des images horribles bien
évidemment qui ont pas de de
place dans un cadre sportif ou dans une
enceinte sportive ou même dans la
vie de tous les jours malheureusement
elles ont elles ont eu lieu donc
évidemment avec les toutes les forces et
les les pouvoirs de décision
qui peut avoir de faire en sorte que ça
n'arrive
plus
aujourd'hui
malheureusement la sphère sportive et en
particulier le le football qui est un
sport très populaire il est le reflet de
notre société je vais pas vous dire
qu'il n'y a pas ceci qu'il n'y a pas
cela on retrouve exactement les mêmes
problèmes qu'on peut avoir dans la
société avec évidemment en plus une
raison médiatique en ce qui concerne le
football qui a un impact beaucoup plus
important c'est arrivé malheureusement
c'est de faire en sorte avec
l'association je le répète des pouvoirs
publics des clubs pour que ça n'arrive
pas et que
aujourd'hui le stade un stade de foot
c'est un lieu ça doit être un lieu
familial et où les familles et les
enfants en particulier euh
doivent avoir la la tranquillité la
sérénité la sécurité de pouvoir y venir
pour
euh voir un spectacle y participer
encourager mais malheureusement voilà il
suffit de de quelques individus qui
évidemment ne viennent pas pour ces
raisons-là et se servent de de ce
lieu qui est un stade comme en lieu de
d'exutoire et ça amè il en suffit d'un
ça arrive bien évidemment euh dans
d'autres disciplines certainement aussi
quand ça arrive avec je vous le
répète un impact médiatique aussi
important qu'en match du dimanche soir
entre deux équipes prestigieuses de du
championnat de France ben
forcément ça prend beaucoup de place je
sais pas pour minimiser ce qui s'est
passé c'est c'est
inacceptable et faire en sorte que ça ça
n'arrive plus et selon vous est-ce que
ça aurait pu être évité et comment
peut-être là vous me demandez des pardon
vous me demandez des des fonctions que
je n'ai pas dans l'absolu tout peut-être
évité maintenant on fait en sorte et je
pense qu'il y a des gens responsables
sur le plan de l'organisation de la
sécurité qui font en sorte de de de
prévoir que tout se passe bien et quel
est votre partage votre regard plutôt
sur le partage des responsabilités
entre l'Association des supporters la LI
la Ligue de foot le ministère je vais
pas dire c'est plus la faute de l'un ou
de l'autre tous tous toutes ces ces ces
domaines-là euh doivent réunir leurs
forces pour faire en sorte que que que
ça n'arrive plus ça passe par quoi euh
certainement euh de la prévention
certainement euh des sanctions lourdes
qui amèent peut-être ces personneslà
même si je suis pas sûr que ceux qui
font de tels actes ont la capacité de
réfléchir mais au moins
de de faire en sorte
que voilà il y a il y a des dans la vie
de tous les jours dans la société il y a
pas à avoir ça et dans dans une enceinte
sportive
euh non plus maintenant je je n'ai pas
moi euh dans ma fonction à titre
personnel la possibilité de pouvoir euh
influencer ou je pense qu'il y a des
gens qui sont suffisamment responsables
ils savent ce qu' peuvent faire ce
qu'ils doivent faire mais c'est un en
rassemblant toutes ces ces pouvoirs de
décision qui pourront amener à avoir une
situation normalisée qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui malheureusement
alors on évoque on a évoqué madame la
Présidente évoquer ce qui s'est passé
dimanche enfin ce weekend lors du match
de ce match de foot
euh il y a quelques mois de cela
l'ancien président de la FFF Noël
legrette indiquait que le racisme
n'existait pas dans le dans le football
euh forcé de constater au vu des images
des propos qui sont tenus d'ailleurs on
le voit quand même sur plusieurs
événements sportifs he ces derniers
temps et notamment des matchs de foot la
question des propos racistes qui sont
tenus et justement vous vous avez une
longue carrière dans ce dans le dans le
monde du football euh est-ce que vous
vous avez déjà été témoins ou confronté
à ce type de propos dans le déroulé de
votre carrière eu est-ce que vous diriez
que ce phénomène a augmenté ou pas oou
il est plus visible aujourd'hui dans le
monde du football et vous avez évoqué
des sanctions euh quel type de sanctions
parce que par exemple ici on est a eu
l'occasion d'auditionner l'association
des supporters qui eux par exemple
étaient complètement contre l'idée de
l'arrêt des matchs parce qu'ils sont
contre les punitions collective mais on
voit bien que ce qui s'est passé par
exemple ce weekend on avait des
supporters lyonnais qui étaient
interdits de stade à Lyon mais qui
pouvaient être dans le stade à Marseille
donc voilà est-ce que quand vous parlez
de sanctions vous pouvez peut-être nous
préciser à quoi vous pensez
exactement je vais vous répondre mais
euh sur le la dernière partie les
sanctions c'est pas à moi je peux vous
donner un avis mais quand je vous donne
un avis c'est pas l' viis du du citoyen
d'idier Deschamps c'est la viis de du
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France donc
est-ce que c'est de mon rôle de donner
un avis là-dessus ça je pense pas comme
sur certains domaines je peux avoir un
avis de là à dire c'est la sanction
c'est pas la bonne il faut plus qu'il y
ait des sanctions plus lourde plus
sévère je pense que ça doit passer par
là après savoir voir s'il faut les
interdire pas les interdire comme vous
venez de le dire qui sont autorisés à
assister de pas assister dans leur stade
mais qui peuvent se
déplacer à tous les niveaux il y a des
gens responsables qui doivent prendre
ces ces décisions évidemment en
échangeant avec les différents
organismes les clubs les associations de
supporteurs les pouvoirs publics la
Ligue la
Fédération c'est c'est leur
responsabilité par
rapport à la première partie et en ce
qui concerne le
racisme bien
évidemment que
durant toute ma carrière j'ai été dans
des situations en France à l'étranger
dans de nombreux vestiè de nombreux
stades mais en toute sincérité
personnellement je n'ai pas été rontter
dans mon
activité sportive
à des situations de de ce type là je ne
vais pas vous dire que par rapport à ce
que je vous ai mis
dire au début qu'il n'y a pas de racisme
dans le football si je vous dis que le
le le football et la sphère sportive le
football qui est un sport très populaire
et en reflet de la société vous allez
retrouver dans le football tous les les
les les bons côtés et les mauvais côtés
de de la société et à titre personnel en
ce qui concerne le racisme j'en été
malheureusement victime euh si j'ai
besoin de vous le rappeler au cas où euh
lorsque en 2016 j'ai eu ma maison en
Bretagne qui a été tagué et je peux vous
assurer que c'est une violence sans nom
et avec des
conséquences par la suite par rapport à
moi et surtout ma famille qui sont
importantes
je j'ai toujours été dans ma première
vie de de
joueur et ma deuxème vie de d'entraîneur
ou de
sélectionnaur voilà je me suis levé
contre toute forme de discrimination
quelle qu'elle soit alors si
aujourd'hui on entend certainement
beaucoup plus parler de de racisme
euh ça vient
euh
forcément d'une part
avec la libération de la parole qui est
une très bonne chose en ce qui concerne
le racisme ou
d'autres formme de
discrimination tant mieux parce que ça
ça lance des alertes ça
amène à des personnes à prendre des
responsabilités alors évidemment quand
ça concerne le football et je suis là
parce que c'est ma profession et c'est
c'est c'est mon domaine
je voudrais pas que vous
stigmatisez plus le football qu'une
autre discipline sportive le monde du
sport n'est pas épargné par ces ces ces
ces problèmes là évidemment quand ça
arrive dans la sphère footballistique
mais même ceux qui ne sont pas forcément
au courant le sont parce que ça
prend évidemment une résonance
médiatique beaucoup plus importante
comme et là c'est plutôt agréable
lorsque et ça nous est ça m'est arrivé
assez fréquemment et à l'équipe de
France aussi de connaître le succès bah
évidemment dans le dans l'émotion le
partage d'émotions ça prend aussi
beaucoup de place mais euh le fait que
aujourd'hui
euh les gens ont la possibilité de
pouvoir parler dire communiquer
alerter c'est c'est essentiel
certainement que c'était pas ou beaucoup
moins le cas les années en arrière donc
vous dites que durant votre carrière
vous n'avez jamais été confronté à des
faits de
racisme enfin concernant tout type de
personne autour de vous j'entends bien
qu'il soit sportif ou dans
l'environnement du sport oui je vous le
confirme en étant joueur dans différents
vestiaires voilà maintenant je je suis
l'activité
euh
quotidienne par rapport à à des actes de
racises qui peut qui peuvent avoir lieu
mais et pourtant j'ai été dans de
nombreux stades vestia pays euh mais
personnellement j'ai j'ai j'ai pas a été
confronté au témoin de de du du d'une
scène de ce type làà
ou rapporter même si vous n'étiez pas on
aurait pu vous rapporter des propos ou
des paroles rapporter après
euh vous savez entre ce que on dirait il
paraî quand vous y êtes pas moi je
préfère parler quand je vois j'entends
de mes propres
yeux après entre ce qui peut être dit et
écrit c'est difficile de faire la part
des choses et la même question toujours
durant votre carrière concernant des
violences sexuelles ou sexistes et des
discriminations en tout
genre avez-vous été confronté non pas
confronté j'ai été informé de par et
vous l'avez cité en préambule de
certains agissements qui auraient eu
lieu à une certaines date que ce soit
claire fontaine et ailleurs mais moi
j'ai pris connaissance comme vous
peut-être beaucoup de personnes à ce
momentl à partir du moment
où au moment des des faits les personnes
ne se sont pas ou ne pouvaient pas ou ne
se sont pas exprimé c'est c'est c'est
difficile de de savoir à moins d'être là
présent mais ça pas été le le
cas pour moi il faut couper le micro et
donc justement quand vous avez été
informé sur cette situation comment ça a
été traité en interne de la
FFF je sais pas je suis pas un
intervenant c'est pas moi qui traite ces
C ces dossiers là que j'en sois informé
[Musique]
comme le public moi j'ai pas de de de
rôle ni de juste pour savoir si vous
avez été informé et si vous avez suivi
des différents dossiers en cours ah non
non non c'est juste ça même si je
comprends que vous n'êtes pas le
président de la FFF mais euh voà mais
même pas de dossier mais informé mais
pas directement après il y a il y a des
actions
judiciaires en
cours c'est pas ça fait pas partie de
mon de mon domaine de de de de
compétence et j'ai pas être j'ai été
informé comme tout à chacun par la voix
des des des médias mais en ayant
aucune aucun rôle au sein de la
fédération par rapport à à à ce domaine
là vous avez évoqué le tag sur votre
maison en 2016 donc peut-être je vais
revenir sur ça et j'aurai deux questions
différentes à cette époque là je suppose
que vous faites référence à à la
nonsélection notamment de Karim Benzema
qui avait dit des champ à céd sous la
pression d'une partie raciste de la
France par qu'on a regardé les articles
comme vous avez évoqué la situation donc
peut-être revenir sur cette sur cette
affaire là et dans la même dans la même
continuité pouvait revenir sur les
raisons qui ont conduit à la non
participation de Karim Benzema au
Mondial du Qatar certains commentateurs
ont avancé que la déchirure musculaire
dont il a été victime n'était pas de
nature à l'empêcher de participer à
certains matchs comment répondez-vous à
ces propos monsieur Benzema avait-il
émis le souhait de participer au match
de l'équipe de France quelle a été la
teneur de vos échanges et pour terminer
vous avez déclaré dans la presse plusut
tôt dans l'année quand je me lève le
lendemain matin on me dit qu'il est
parti il avait décidé de partir par un
vol commercial je lui envoie un sms il
m'a répondu quand il atterrit c'est la
vérité il n en a qu'une seule et c'est
celle-là Karim m'a dit lui-même qu'il
n'aurait pas été prêt monsieur Benzema a
commenté ses propos sur Instagram par
les mots mais quelle audace et vous a
implicitement traité de menteur comment
lui
répondez-vous
euh je vais reprendre au départ on me
posait beaucoup de questions en même
temps
euh je ne sais pas si
euh l'acte le tag de ma maison est lié
ou non à la sélection de à la non
sélection de de Karim Benzema je ne sais
pas d'ailleurs qui est l'auteur
puisqu'il n'a pas été euh
identifié en ce qui
concerne la la sélection ou la non
sélection d'un joueur je vous
rappellerai que je suis sélectionneur de
l'équipe de France et je sélectionne des
joueurs qui ont la nationalité française
et mes choix sont des choix sportifs
euh après vous êtes un petit peu dans
dans l'interprétation de ce qui peut
être dit euh où écrit je veux bien qu'on
rentre dans le détail je sais pas si
c'est
euh l'endroit pour
euh
refaire l'histoire entre guillemets de
ce qui s'est passé euh euh à DOA lors de
la la Coupe du monde mais à partir du
moment où je me suis exprimé vous avez
repris certains de mes propos euh
quand
je je prends ma parole et j'annonce euh
je parle évidemment je vais vous
reprendre l'inspression oui dans chaque
situation il y a qu'une vérité mais il y
a plusieurs versions je vais pas vous
amener des éléments pour vous montrer
bien ou vous confirmer que ce que j'ai
peux dire est la
vérité mais c'est factuel et euh j'ai
dit ce qui s'était passé euh comme vous
l'avez repris c'est peut-être repris de
de de de certains médias mais la la
situation elle s'est passée exactement
euh comme ça si vous voulez plus de
détails je peux vous donner aussi des
échanges de de de SMS euh voilà mais euh
je pense pas que ça fera avancer les
choses et d'ailleurs pour votre
information si vous le savez pas
euh j'ai une je suis en procédure euh
aussi
contre un journaliste qui s'est permis
d'affirmer des
choses donc la
procédure est en cours à partir
d'éléments dont il disposait on verra
bien la
justice rendra son son verdict mais euh
j'ai pas à inventer des histoires après
vous savez ils
peuvent quelle personne vous allez
accorder du du crédit entre ce que vous
pouvez lire et entendre et ce qui s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé réellement moi
je vous répète le si j'ai pas envie de
de de parler je suis pas là pour faire
rire quand je prends la parole et je
m'exprime sur un point bien précis je
suis pas là pour je dis ce qui s'est
passé en donnant plus ou moins de
détails je suis pas là pour argumenter
et d'autant plus que en ayant une
procédure en cours je peux pas me
permettre de de donner des éléments
détaillés alors euh c'est pas une
question de vous croire ou pas puisque
vous êtes sous sererment donc on part du
principe que tout ce que vous dites est
la réalité en tout cas c'est que c'est
la vérité euh moi je veux juste revenir
sur une partie de ce que vous avez dit
mais peut-être que vous pourrez nous
préciser les choses quand vous avez
évoqué la question de la sélection vous
avez dit moi je sélectionne des joueurs
qui ont la nationalité française et du
coup comme la question portait sur Karim
Benzema ça veut dire qu'il n'aurait pas
laité française non parce que vous
répondez à ma question en disant cela
donc c'est juste que si vous pouvez nous
préciser les choses
voilà j'ai été porter ce maillot de
l'équipe de France qui est la plus belle
choses qui me soit arrivé dans ma vie
professionnelle vous savez la la
diversité dans le dans le sport et
surtout dans le football qui est un
sport populaire moi j'ai toujours
considéré que c'était une force et une
richesse donc je n'ai pas
n'associez pas ou n'interprétez pas
l'association du fait de prendre des des
joueurs qui ont la nationalité
française par rapport à Karim Benzema il
est il est français comme tous les
joueurs que que je sélectionne même si
certains c'est un
sujet qui qui qui est proche de celui-là
avec la liberté quand certains joueurs
qui sont des des binationaux de pouvoir
choisir un pays plutôt que qu'un autre
c'est une liberté qu'ils ont toujours eu
donc non non moi c'est simplement quand
je vous dis des joueurs qui ont la
nationalité française c'est par rapport
à mes choix et mes choix ce sont des
choix sportifs je n'ai pas de critère
autre que l'aspect sportif pour
sélectionner ou non sélectionner un
joueur merci pour la précision c'est
important parce que comme je vous posais
vraiment la question sur monsieur
Benzema en fait come quand vous répondez
ça ça laisse voilà ça ça met un doute en
fait c'est pour ça que c'était bien de
de le préciser et je vous reposer la
question euh je voulais revenir
sur le plan social qui a eu lieu à la
Fédération française de football en 2021
qui d'après qui a été très critiqué
d'ailleurs dont la gestion était très
critiquée par l'igesr euh quel est votre
avis euh et votre regard sur ce plan
social
si je termine la question parce que
comme vous l'avez précisé vous-même vous
êtes salarié de la FFF donc voilà tout
le plan social concerné concerné pas
directement mais concerné des salariés
de la FFF
oui euh oui je suis un salarié de la
Fédération je suis un salarié un peu
particulier quand même avec une fonction
particulière donc sincèrement si vous me
demander ce qu'il y a dans le pan je
suis incapable de vous
répondre je je ne sais pas je sais qu'il
y a des actions comme le nouveau euh
président Philippe Dialo aussi a a fait
un pas social même si vous me demandez
aujourd'hui je peux pas vous dire j'ai
pas connaissance de de de ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur donc je peux pas réagir
évidemment ça concerne c'est pour ça que
ce que je vous ai dit en amant c'est pas
pour fuir euh vos réponse moi je suis
pas dans le quotidien de la fédération
à j'ai une fonction bien particulière de
sélectionneur et elle se situe
quasi
exclusivement
hors siège de la fédération je reçois
bien évidemment quand il y a un mail des
emails du personnel j'en reçois je les
lis pas tous parce que je suis pas
concerné non plus par tout ce qui peut
se passer et non pas que je
veuille me différencier des autres mais
ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas du tout de mon de mon
ressort et de mon demande de
compétenence en tant que que
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France de
de de donner un avis ou de de de
participer à à à à ces décisions ça
c'est en rôle de de dirigeant de
président de vice-président de Comex
euh voilà moi je je garde ma place de
salarié en sachant que je suis pas un
salarié comme les autres bien
évidemment alors justement puisque vous
évoquez le Comex les vice-présidents et
les rôles des uns et des autres est-ce
que vous savez vous pouvez nous indiquer
à quel moment monsieur Dialo est devenu
vice-président de la fédération et à
quel moment il a intégré le
Comex désolé mais
non je sais pas du tout je sais qu'à un
moment il a été même trésorier mais je
serais incapable de de vous donner la
date d'entrée quand il est devenu Vince
président quand il a intégré le Comex
euh et encore même quand il est devenu
puisqu'il a été président par intérim
une période avant d'être confirmé en
tant que président de la de la
fédération mais euh euh non c'est pas
des éléments euh euh dont je dispose
aujourd'hui et donc et pendant mes plus
de 10 ans que je suis sélectionneur
c'était pas la la partie qui qui
m'intéressait je n'étais pas confronté à
ces à ce domaine-là ou à ces domaines
là alors peut-être deux autres questions
qui concernent plutôt monsieur Legret
euh est-ce que vous et votre staff vous
avez été gêné
dans dans vos missions par les
dysfonctionnements et l'implosion du
tandem Monsieur legrette et Madame
Ardouin donc ça c'est c'était la
première question et pourquoi est-ce que
vous et votre staff vous avez en quelque
sorte trompu avec Madame Ardouin à
l'euro
2021 je rigole mais je devrais pas
rigoler parce que ce que vous dites
c'est grave je sais pas d'où vous pouvez
affirmer non c'est une question mais en
affirmant ce que vous avez affirmé
surtout sur la deuxème
oui une interprétation qui est pas du
tout le la bonne dans le fonctionnement
je vous cache pas que euh sur décision
du président Noël lerette qui avait
délégué Florence sardouin
euh qui était directrice générale et qui
était qui travaillait il avait mis en
mission par rapport à l'équipe de France
à masculine je vais pas vous dire de mal
de
de Madame Ardoin euh le temps qu'elle a
pu passer
euh avec nous en équipe de France euh et
de ce qu'elle a pu faire pour permettre
de pas perdre de temps de prendre des
décisions mais c'est une
décision de notre président à l'époque
qui était monsieur monsieur Leret
évidemment quand il y a eu il y a une
période un peu plus enfin trouble je
sais pas si c'est le mot mais où il y a
un peu de perturbation ben il y avait
des habitudes où ça se faisait
naturellement ben il y a un
fonctionnement qui change sur décision
du président moi le maître mot c'est
m'adapté et avec mon staff je me
suis adapté
euh bien évidemment euh j'ai oublié la
deuxème partie pardon où vous
m'affirmiez oui vous posz la question
pardon du coup par rapport à la
justement avec Madame les relations avec
Madame Ardis l'euro
2021 c'est c'est bon je vais y arriver
euh c'est une décision du
président après euh euh
mon pouvoir de décision il est sur le
choix des joueurs et personne va va
venir me dire qui il faut prendre ou qui
il faut pas prendre peu importe qui peut
avoir des des des des commentaires des
uns des autres et certaines personnes
qui font pas partie du monde sportif ça
ça a pas d'importance ça c'est mon
pouvoir de décision après le le le le
présdisant il décide il y a pas de
démarche de ma part bon peut-être à
travers ce qui peut qui peut être dit et
écrit parce que je suis pas complètement
déconnecté de ce mondelà que j'aurais pu
demander ou quoi que ce soit ou qu'elle
soit plus avec nous c'est une décision
de mon président à l'époque il y a pas à
la discuter comme
aujourd'hui avec le nouveau président si
le président est en conférence où il est
devant vous il va dire quelque chose
j'ai pas commenter ce qu'il dit c'est
pas de mon ressort il est président lui
en tant que Président il a des décisions
à prendre qu'elle me plaise ou qu'elle
me plaise pas euh c'est de son ressort
je vais élargir peut-être un peu plus
encore le choix des joueurs il me
revient mais depuis que je suis
sélectionneur j'ai un staff avec moi
euh j'ai la possibilité de proposer de
choisir les personnes qui je pense sont
le plus compétentes pour être à mes
côtés mais si j'ai mon président qui me
dit lui non c'est pas possible je je le
prends pas je peux pas et je suis pas
voilà il y a une hiérarchie dans toute
domaine professionnel moi j'ai fait en
sorte depuis que je suis sélectionnaur à
à rester dans mon domaine
euh à avoir mon pouvoir de décision en
ce qui concerne le sportif je vais pas
mimisser dans d'autres domaines qui sont
pas de de ma compétence et ne seraitce
pas respect par rapport à la hiérarchie
vous parliez du la directrice générale
il peut avoir il y a eu des changements
bien évidemment
euh récemment
euh parce qu'ils ont été décidés comme
ça une question notre collègue Stéphane
buûchou merci Madame la présidence
madame la Présidente pardon bonjour
Stéphane Buchou député de la vandé
vice-président de de cette commission
d'enquête je voulais revenir sur sur ce
que vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
vous nous avez vous nous avez dit ne
jamais avoir été le témoin durant votre
belle et longue carrière ça c'est mes
propos à moi
euh c'est sincère euh vous n'avez jamais
été le témoin de de violences sexuelles
ou sexistes de de de propos racistes
homophobes et cetera et cetera euh et
que vous en avez pris connaissance comme
je dirais beaucoup d'entre nous par le
biais des
médias ma question est la suivante je
voudrais savoir si une fois que vous
avez eu connaissance de ces affaires qui
touchait aussi le football et d'autres
sports est-ce que dans le rôle qui est
le vôtre qui est pas n'importe quel rôle
celui de sélectionneur de l'équipe de
France vous avez mis en place avec votre
staff des actions de sensibilisation
première question deuxième question une
fois que ces affaires sont sorties
est-ce qu'il y a eu des échanges avec la
direction de la fédération en
l'occurrence son président et sa
directrice générale pour échanger savoir
s'il y avait là encore encore des
actions à mener au sein au sein de au
sein de l'équipe dit autrement après que
tout ça est été connu est-ce qu'il y a
eu des actions particulières ou ça a
continué comme
avant merci de vos compliments la
question aussi mais c'est pas facile de
répondre non je vous confirme en toute
je suis sous serment je suis pas là
voilà j'aurais pu en tant que que
qu'entraîneur de
club dans l'enceinte d'un stade dans des
tribunes ça m'est pas arrivé je vais pas
dire et ou dans un vestière avec quand
j'étais joueur ou là en étant entraîneur
de par ce que je viens vous dire et et
les moments de d'immense joie qu'on a
connu avec justement si le le sport et
le football a cette capacité à à
fabriquer des émotions mais surtout à
réunir à réunir peu importe la diversité
quelle qu'elle soit alors après ça dure
le temps que ça dure mais on n'est pas
là pour pouvoir malheureusement régler
les problèmes quotidiens de des de
chaque Français ou de chaque française
vous savez quand les joueurs moi quand
j'étais joueur en équipe de France
c'était déjà le cas et depuis que je
suis devenu
sélectionneur être joueur de l'équipe de
France de de de football
quand on vient et qu'on porte ce maillot
c'est déjà un privilège un honneur il y
a
évidemment beaucoup de devoirs ils sont
pas là pour recevoir recevoir après
partager des joies et des émotions quand
il y a des succès oui bien évidemment
mais ils ont des devoirs par rapport à à
l'image qui est
communiqué par rapport et ça c'est aussi
très important pour moi le fait d'être
de bons exemples pour la jeune
génération je peux vous assurer qu'ils
ont tous bien conscience après ils ont
leur liberté de pouvoir s'engager et ils
sont beaucoup engagés dans des des des
différentes causes après il y a la
sensibilité des uns et des autres bien
évidemment moi l'image qui me
tient par-dessus tout o le plus à cœur
c'est que cette équipe de France doit
euh communiquer une image de d'unité et
de solidarité sur et en dehors du
terrain avec des joueurs français bien
évidemment mais venant de de de de de
ayant des des des des cultures des
histoires euh forcément euh différentes
s'il y a un mot qui est très important
mais de nos jours dans notre société
c'est il a plus beaucoup de place c'est
tolérance et pouvoir accepter la
différence et pas dire moi je pense ça
ça c'est bien ça c'est mal tout dépend
de chacun et le football dans un
vestiaire ou là par rapport à l'équipe
de France il y a sincèrement il y a pas
eu à à intervenir puisquil y a pas le
problème il y est pas il y a pas parce
qu'il y a un groupe qui est composé de
de joueurs différents avec des cultures
différentes des religions différentes
des opinions politiques différentes des
sensibilités différentes ça ça concerne
chacun d'entre eux dans leur quotidien
là ils se retrouvent pour porter le
maillot évidemment il y a ce qui se
passe sur le terrain et l'objectif
sportif c'est c'est celui-là le plus
important mais il y a une vie de de
groupe quand on part pour des grandes
compétitions en contant s'il y a une
préparation on part sur sur un mois et
demi 2 mois et on est h 24 ensemble donc
qui qui est des qu's a aussi en plus de
leur énorme qualité de de footballeur
que humainement ils aient des capacités
à à vivre ensemble oui ça c'est quelque
chose d'important il y a pas de sujet
tabou moi à aucun moment depuis que je
suis sélectionneur j'ai d à des joueurs
tu parles pas tu parles pas de ce sujet
tu dois dire ça tu dois dois dire autre
chose j'ai des discussions avec eux
collectives j'ai des discussions des
entretiens individuels où je m'adapte je
fais en sorte au-delà des footballeurs
qui sont de connaître le mieux possible
chacun d'entre eux humainement pour
justement savoir leur parcours leur
historique leur sens je vais devoir vous
interrompre je suis désolé Ah je suis
trop long mais parce que nous avons
d'autres questions et puis je suis
également maître du temps nous avons une
question de Monsieur Pierre-Henri Dumont
et peut-être que vous aurez l'occasion
de terminer vos
propos merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le sélectionneur merci pour
votre présence vos propos puis aussi
pour ce que vous avez fait depuis de
nombreuses années maintenant à la tête
de l'équipe de France
euh je pense d'abord que c'est pas
forcément le rôle de la Commission
d'enquête de juger des sélections ou pas
des des différents
joueurs sans faire de jugement de valeur
les meilleurs résultats ont été obtenus
sans la personne qui a été évoquée lors
des grandes compétitions c'est dernières
années ceci étant dit j'auraai deux
questions euh vous avez évoqué monsieur
Deschamp le fait que lors de votre
carrière de joueur euh votre précédente
carrière en tout cas avant d'être
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France vous
n'aviez pas fait l'expérience de fit de
racisme euh on sait malheureusement que
l'Italie est parfois en pointe sur ces
sujets-là malheureusement euh il y a des
attaques des cris de singe parfois des
propos des champs euh raciste homophobe
dans certains cas dans des stades en
Italie lorsque vous étiez vous joueurs
en Italie à la Juventus de Turin ou même
entraîneur de cette équipe est-ce que
vous aviez dans ce pu expérimenter ce
genre de de geste ou pas et vous aviez
évoqué euh à la fin de la préscente
conclus expression que vous vouliez
mieux connaître humainement euh vos
joueurs vous avez des joueur qui joue
actuellement en Italie euh par exemple
le gardien de l'équipe de France macman
joue en Italie il s'est exprimé
fortement contre le racisme qu'il a pu
expérimenter dans dans les stades est-ce
que vous en avez parlé avec lui on sait
que c'est aussi un poste qui est
compliqué le poste de gardien de but qui
est le dernier rempart de l'équipe et
donc ça est-ce que ça peut selon vous
avoir une incidence sur les performances
des joueurs le fait d'expérimenter ce
racisme ma ma deuxième question concerne
les relations avec l'ancien président de
la FFF euh est-ce que vous estimez que
votre relation avec Monsieur Legret
était une relation simple d'employeur à
employer
où est-ce qu'il y avait une relation un
peu plus forte qui s'est tissé du fait
de votre longévité au poste de
sélectionneur et on pourrait le
comprendre parce que vous êtes
probablement les sélectionneurs qui est
resté le plus longtemps en poste à la
tête de de l'équipe de
France et est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que Monsieur Legret vous a un peu
utilisé peut-être comme une sorte de
paravant au moment où il était fragilisé
par exemple en vous proposant une
prolongation de contrat qui va jusqu'à
2026 si je dis pas de bêtises alors que
la tradition veut que ça aille de grande
compétition en grande compétition et que
donc la prolongation qui vous a été
attribuée à l'issue de la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar aurait pu entre guillemets dans
les normes habituelles s'arrêter après
l'Euro prochain en Allemagne je vous
remercie c'est difficile de faire des
réponses courtes parce que les questions
sont sont nombreuses donc je je vous si
je suis sûr que vous savez faire ça vous
savez faire une réponsete mais le temps
est parce qu'on a d'autres questions oui
ben je me doute
euh en ce qui concerne le le RAC le
racisme pardon il y a beaucoup plus ces
derniers temps de
de d' d'incidents qui se
passe je sais pas s'il y en avait pas où
il y en avait et on nen parlait pas je
vous réaffirme que moi dans ma carrière
de joueur je n'ai pas été
confronté spécifiquement et
personnellement à de de de de telle
situation qu'aujourd'hui et je suis pas
déconnecté je regarde les matchs il y a
des matchs où certains joueurs vous avez
cé mcmeant oou il y en a d'autres ou
ponctuellement il y a un problème de
racisme et forcément ça pas ça ça a pas
lieu lieu d'être en restant sur Mike
mean je pense que vous allez à des
conclusions un peu attives par rapport à
ses performances même si vous vous avez
sans doute la capacité à pouvoir juger
du de la performance des des des des
joueurs mais
évidemment le joueur de foot quel qu'il
soit ce sont pas des robots ce sont des
êtres humains et je sais trop bien pour
avoir été moi aussi joueur de foot
pendant de longues années ben quand
c'est une période où on a on n'est pas
en confiance où on peut avoir des soucis
dans le domaine privé bah ça influe sur
la la performance sur le terrain donc à
travers les discussions que je peux
avoir avec mes joueurs euh en tête à
tête ça arrive fréquemment de pouvoir
aborder des sujets qui sortent du
domaine sportif mais si j'ai cette
possibilité là avec eux c'est justement
du fait de de déjà au départ de bien les
connaître de tisser une relation de
confiance et dans cette relation de
confiance ils savent très bien que la
discussion que nous avons
elle reste entre le joueur et
moi tout au plus je suis pas pas là pour
les conseiller je leur donne mon avis
par rapport à mon vécu et mon expérience
mais ça sera toujours leur décision
parce que c'est leur carrière à un
moment ça peut arriver qu'il peuvent me
me demander ce que j'en pense mais je
leur dis toujours c'est votre décision
je peux amener des des éléments
euh après en ce qui concerne la la la la
la relation avec mon ancien président
Noël legrette
euh depuis le départ nous avons eu une
relation professionnelle lui en étant
président il m'a choisi en tant que que
sélectionneur et puis au fil des années
de se pratiquer de se voir de discuter
benah forcément il y a une relation qui
se crée euh qui va au-delà du du
relationnel de par tout ce que l'on a pu
réaliser ensemble et qui a permis euh à
l'équipe de France de d'obtenir les
résultats qu'elle a obtenu mais euh et
de son côté et de mon côté surtout de
mon côté je l'ai jamais considéré euh
différemment même si on avait ça m'
arrivé de de déjeuner quelquefois avec
lui de parler football il est venu
fréquemment à Clairefontaine dans toutes
les compétition euh et il était là avec
nous à nos côtés pour échanger parler
parler football mais dans mon esprit ça
a toujours été euh mon Président al je
disais certains me l'ont reproché parce
que j'ai dit mon Président c'était le
président de tous les salariés de de la
Fédération comme aujourd'hui Philippe
Dialo est mon Président et et malgré ou
je veux pas dire malgré parce que c'est
négatif avec cette
relation de confiance où on il
m'apéciait je l'appréciais euh je me
suis jamais permis de le tutoyer ou de
le pour moi en face de moi c'était
toujours le président de la Fédération
Française de Football j'ai fait un peu
plus court très bien j'allais juste vous
interrompre donc c'est parfait madame la
rapporteur a une question pour
vous euh oui peut-être juste revenir sur
cette prolongation justement de
sélectionneur selon nos informations et
lors d'audition d'ailleurs qu'on a eu
l'occasion d'avoir dans cadre de cette
commission la prolongation jusqu'en 2026
de votre contrat serait intervenue sans
que le Comex de l'ff soit n'est ni
consulté ni l'assemblée générale
justement est-ce que vous pouvez revenir
sur alors c'est une personne qu'on a
auditionné ici qui nous l'a dit donc
c'est pour ça que je reviens dessus al
alors juste je termine du coup est-ce
que vous pouvez revenir justement dans
les conditions parce que nous dans
l'audition si je dis pas de bêtises mais
jeevérifierai le compte-rendu la
personne vous a dit que Monsieur Legret
vous avez reçu et il vous avait indiqué
qu'il souhaitait vous prolonger et en
fait il avait pas du tout demandé l'avis
du COMEX ou de l'assemblée générale de
la FFF alors
euh je peux pas vous dire et c'est pas
de mon ressort si le président est censé
aviser le Comex ou pas euh l'assemblée
générale elle a été avisée puisqu'elle a
eu lieu le lendemain donc c'est
difficile de d'aviser des personnes ils
sont 600 il y a tout le monde le monde
du football amateur donc et il a il
voulait annoncer ma prolongation au
moment de
cette assemblée générale à laquelle je
participe j'ai participé régulièrement à
celle d'hiver parce à celle d'été c'est
plutôt bon signe que j'y sois pas ça
veut dire qu'on est en compétition soit
en championnat d'Europe ou en ou en
Coupe du monde mais par rapport à et
vous je reviens par rapport à cette
prolongation euh dans votre analyse
euh si les choses s'étaient passées
comme elles se sont toujours passées
depuis le premier jour je suis devenu
sélectionneur j'aurais pas eu à à avoir
une prolongation de contrat parce
qu'elle était toujours prévu avant que
je parte en compétition
si ça été le cas en 2014 ça a été le cas
en 2016 c'était le cas 2018 et c'était
le cas
2021 où
et pour des
raisons du comment je vais dire ça que
que
que que le président tenait compte sans
vouloir parler à sa place de un
sélectionnaire qui part pour une
compétition avec des joueurs et il y a
eu un historique pour ça dans la gestion
et dans le management et je l'ai connu
en tant que joueur aussi quand vous
savez que cette personneel
elle est censé s'arrêter après la
compétition c'est quand même un peu plus
compliqué dans le management et la
gestion par rapport aux joueurs ce qui
joue ceux qui jouent pas vous allez me
dire ça nous a pas empêché d'être vice
champion du monde au Qatar malgré tout
puisque les joueurs savaient très bien
que après cette compétition je n'avais
plus de de contrat donc c'est la
situation qui a amené à faire une
prolongation et je vous le répète mais
ça pas été le cas ces décisions du
président voilà non pas que je suis pour
ou contre il l'avait fait jusqu'à là les
années précédentes là il les a pas fait
il a pas fait je pense qu'il sera lui
aussi présent devant vous si vous voulez
lui demander les raisons qui l'ont amené
à à à modifier sa position avant la
Coupe du
Monde il vous
répondra
merci alors juste peut-être pour revenir
sur ce que vous nous avez indiqué quand
vous avez vous nous avez dit que vous
n'aviez jamais été témoins ou assisté à
des faits de racisme dans le
football durant toute votre carrière si
je vous cite le nom de Joseph Antoine
Bell est-ce que ça vous rappelle quelque
chose oui heureusement oui j'ai eu
l'occasion de jouer au moins une année
avec lui au girondin de Bordeaux
que lors d'un match il on lui a lancé
des bananes au stade Vélodrome vous
étiez à ce moment-là vous étiez sur le
terrain j'y étais à ce momentl voilà
c'est vrai mais j'ai pas c'est j'ai
pas sorti ça
de de de de ma tête mais maintenant que
vous le dites j'ai fait j'ai commencé le
football professionnel en
80 85 donc c'est beaucoup beaucoup de de
mage dans des
stades forcément mais quand je dis
confronter dans l'environnement ce qui
peut se passer dans un stade vous allez
peut-être m'en sortir me parler de
l'Italie c'est possible qu'à un moment
il y a eu un incident à un moment sur un
stade j'ai joué des matchs tous les 3
jours moi quand je dis j'ai pas été
confronté personnellement c'est-à-dire
au cœur de mon activité que ça soit en
tant que joueur dans un vestière où il y
a un problème entre deux joueurs
d'origine différente ou autre euh ou
dans ma dans mon métier d'entraîneur que
ça soit à l'entraînement ou ou dans la
gestion d'une équipe ou en tant que
sélectionneur par rapport entre joueurs
dans l'enceinte ou autour d'un stade
alors je me suis peut-être mal exprimé
vous allez en trouver certainement où je
faisais partie mais c'est dans
l'environnement non pas que je minimise
m l'impact que ça ça a pu avoir et
l'importance que ça prend encore
plus aujourd'hui mais je je le répète je
parlais vraiment de de
de comment je vais dire l'environement
proche et qui concerne le vestiaire et
l'équipe en fait je je suis revenu
dessus parce que justement quand j'ai
posé la question c'était de savoir si
vous aviez pu être témoins de fait de de
racisme dans le foot donc forcément bien
sûr que je pense qu'on trouvera d'autres
exemples là-dessus mais si vous voulez
dans le cadre des auditions y compris
d'ailleurs de de certains sportifs ce
qui revient régulièrement c'est le fait
qu'ils sont un peu en fait laissés seul
face à ce qu'ils subissent en tant que
sportif quand ils ont soit des cris de
singe soit comme là des jets de banane
comme on a pu le voir dans d'autres
terrains des champs homophobes qui
concernent pas forcément les sportifs
mais dans le stade et du coup ce qui
revient beaucoup c'est ça c'est le
sentiment d'être laissé seul et de
demander aux sportifs de faire les de
porter plainte de de de faire tout ce
travail là un peu seul sans être
accompagné forcément par sa fédération
on parle du football aujourd'hui parce
que vous êtes là mais ça concerne
d'autres d'autres disciplines est-ce que
justement de votre point de vue il y
aurait pas quelque chose ou un
dispositif ou un accompagnement à avoir
vis-à-vis de ces sportifs qui on leur
demande de performer sur le stade et qui
au moment où justement il termin bah ils
subissent parfois des propos extrêmement
racistes qui n'ont pas forcément enfin
voilà qui n'ont pas le réflexe de
traiter est-ce que justement on pourrait
pas envisager des de seortter
particiivil de porter plainte
systématiquement voilà des dispositifs
comme ça là je vous parle vraiment en
tant que sélectionneur vous avez des
joueurs sur votre responsabilité est-ce
que c'est pas des choses vers les qu'on
peut
envisager envisager c'est c'est une une
liberté qu'ils ont et qui devrait qu'on
qu'il soit accompagné c'est ça me semble
tout à
fait logique c'est je vous le répète si
je vous dis que je m'élève contre toute
discrimination je me l'attribue d'abord
avant même c'est facile de dire aux
autres de faire et soi-même faire ce
qu'on a envie mais bien évidemment qu'il
y a des choses à améliorer après c'est
le ressenti de chacun d'aller jusqu'à
des actions euh euh des procédures
judiciaires ou pas mais évidemment que
les les instances ont ont un rôle
important et quand ça ça arrive même si
vous me
reparlez je l'avais pas en mémoire par
rapport à à Joseph Antoine belle euh
quand ça des des événements arrivent
comme ça je peux vous assurer que en
interne par rapport à l'ensemble des
joueurs la solidarité elle est là le
soutien est là mais mais après ça peut
pas aller au-delà évidemment c'est c'est
le rôle des des des des des institutions
de faire en sorte de de de de les
accompagner pour faire en sorte de
d'éradiquer ce ce problème là dans un
premier temps de pouvoir le le réduire
et puis pour qu'on en arrive je l'espère
le plutôt possible à ne plus en parler
une question de Monsieur piqumal
oui bonjour monsieur Deschamp donc
François piqumal député de la 4e
circonscription de HauteGaronne vous
l'avez euh vous l'avez dit tout au long
de votre propos et je vous rejoins
l'équipe de France de football et plus
que l'équipe de France de football dans
notre pays et vous en avait une part
j'allais dire de responsabilité mais pas
de responsabilité mais heureuse une
responsabilité heureuse c'est que ça
préexistait avant
1998 mais c'est véritablement à partir
de 98 et la victoire à la Coupe du monde
qu'il y a eu un nouvel effet d'attente
sociétale ou sociale autour de l'équipe
de France et qu'on a vu vu au travers de
différents épisodes que ce soit bon on
souvient tous de nacena avec tout ce que
ça a causé comme problème sportif
évidemment mais aussi au niveau
politique
d'intervention du personnel politique
dans dans ce qui aurait pu rester après
tout un épiphénomène sportif et depuis
que vous avez repris l'équipe de France
je vais je vais commencer par par un
compliment vous avez mis vous avez remis
les équipe de France au centre du
football mondial via la victoire en 80
en 2018 et et les excellents résultats
qu'il y a eu depuis et
finalement en vous
écoutant j'ai l'impression que vous vous
situez vraiment dans votre rôle de
sélectionneur et que vous l'avez bien
défini que vous ne sortez pas de ça mais
moi j'ai envie de vous dire que vous
êtes plus que un sélectionneur aux yeux
de beaucoup de gens vous êtes une figure
figure nationale connue populaire
discuter critiquer c'est comme ça pour
toutes les personnes publiques et
finalement vous mettez dans un rôle de
subordination qui est certainement
véridique en terme de contrat que vous
avez mais si on demande à tout à chacun
est-ce que vous connaissez quelqu'un qui
représente la Fédération Française de
Football je pense que votre nom sera
parmi les premiers à sortir et moi ce
que j'aimerais savoir il y a eu plein de
questions que j'aurais aimé vous poser
mais qui ont été posées par mes
collègues
aujourd'hui face au cas de racisme
d'homophobie de discrimination de
violence sexuelle et sexiste en tout
genre à la parole qui se libère et à
l'urgence aussi qu'on ressent notamment
au travers des auditions qu'on a pu
mener du football amateur du sport
amateur de manière générale en passant
par le football mais pas que jusqu'au
monde professionnel est-ce que votre
rôle quelque part c'est pas de d'être
comme on dit au Barça plus qu'un club et
plus qu'un sélectionneur en en disant et
en affirmant qu'il faut donner plus de
visibilité au niveau de l'équipe de
France masculine à des actions contre le
racisme contre l'homophobie contre les
violences sexuelles et
sexistes un peu déconnecté parce que les
joueurs et l'équipe de France sont
amenés à faire à titre personnel ou
collectivement plusieurs actions l'une
des dernières c'est par rapport au resto
du cœur après vous savez il y a énorm de
de d'association euh
elles ont un combat et pour ces
associations heureusement qu'elles
existent le seul combat c'est le combat
de chaque association vous savez les
sollicitations qui qu'il peut avoir
c'est impossible de répondre à toutes
les sollicitations les joueurs sont
appliqués évidemment que et et moi
personnellement au-delà du rôle de de de
de sportif et le football à un rôle
sociétal alors quand il y a la victoire
tout va bien à 98 vous en parlez
évidemment ça durit beaucoup beaucoup
plus longtemps qu'en qu'en 2018 mais on
va pas régler les problèmes du quotidien
après excusez-moi j'ai j'ai j'ai une
fonction bien évidemment en tant que que
que sélectionneur de l'équipe de France
avec une responsabilité je laffuie pas
je l'assume je prendre des
décisions je suis comme ça j'ai des
peut-être des principes on les aime on
les aime pas chacun a son domaine et son
pouvoir de de décision mais je suis
avant tout un citoyen français et à ce
titre-là je suis dans la vie même en
étant dans mare dans mon ma sphère
sportive je suis dans la vie de de tous
les jours je vous rassure j'ai pas les
les mêmes problèmes que Monsieur et
Madame dans le quotidien bien évidemment
mais après j'ai quand même la liberté
aussi de pouvoir m'exprimer ou pas
m'exprimer moi moi j'ai parti du
principe il y en a qui trouveront ça
bien ou pas bien vous m'entendrez jamais
et vous vous ne m'avez jamais entendu
parler de politique depuis que je suis
dans le
sport non pas que j'ai pas des idées non
pas que j'ai pas même des convictions
parce que j'estime peut-être excusez-moi
l'expression
conement que c'est pas ma place parce
que j'ai un rôle dans le sportif et je
veux pas mêler les deux mais je suis
citoyen mais quand je m'
comme je m'exprime aujourd'hui c'est pas
le citoyen Didier Deschamp qui s'exprime
devant vous et qui sera des certaines
phrases seront reprises j'ai bien
conscience que c'est Didier Deschamps
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France et
ça engage pas que moi moi je dissocie
les deux je suis la même personne mais
j'ai une vie professionnelle une vie
privée c'est mon choix je peux avoir
cette liberté là je dis pas après il y
en a qui vont me critiquer ou peu
importe ça ça pas pour moi c'est pas
c'est pas un souci mais de par une
phrase ou une de mes réponses même vous
ici les personnes qui sont là vous vous
allez interpréter d'une façon vous d'une
autre moi je sais ce que je veux dire
mais j'ai quand même cette liberté là et
je parle des joueurs moi à titre
personnel aussi je m'investis après j'ai
une sensibilité je dis pas que j'en ai
pas quand il y a eu il y a quelques
années on m'a demandé de participer avec
Monsieur le Maire à à un film par
rapport à l'homophobie j'y ai participer
si on me demande de participer tous les
3 mois d'être
présent je peux pas sincèrement je je
juste je finis excusez-moi le fait moi
je m'engage j'ai une cause qui me tient
à cœur c'est celle des
enfants et tout ce que je fais à travers
l'association ou les pièes jaunes ou
même à trit person n sans que ça
devienne médiatique voilà je suis
sensible à cette cause là je dis pas que
les autres méritent pas d'être défendu
au contraire tout moi je fais beaucoup
par rapport à celle-là parce que
aujourd'hui dans la vie la chose la plus
importante pour moi c'est le sourire
d'un enfant et ils ont tous droit à
avoir accès à ce sourire et
malheureusement c'est pas le cas alors
je vais pas résoudre tous les problèmes
mais je fais en sorte
de le temps que je peux y accorder et du
fait d'être Didier Deschamp le
sélectionneur de pouvoir aller dans ce
sens-l vous l'avez dit le sport n'a pas
de couleur politique la preuve en est
c'est que ce groupe de travail est
transpartisan et que vous avez parmi
nous tous les collègues je pense toutes
les couleurs du de l'Assemblée nationale
représenté mis à part le RN qui a
souhaité quitter la commission d'enquête
voilà et je voudrais revenir sur le
sujet dont vous parliez précédemment
concernant les discriminations et
Monsieur Leret s'était prononcé contre
le port d'un brassard de soutien à la
cause LGBT craignant de faire passer les
joueurs pour des donneurs de leçon
étiez-vous personnellement favorable au
port de ce brassard en avez-vous discuté
avec Monsieur Noël grret avez-vous
regretté que la FIFA décide finalement
d'interdire le port d'un tel brassard au
motif qu' n'était pas fourni par
elle
pardon je l'éteins je l'allume nous
avons effectivement toutes les équipes
nationales par décision de l'UEFA sur un
match
de de
qualification Ligue des Nations où
toutes les équipes tous les capitaines
s'étaient mis d'accord et l'UEFA avait
décidé de porter le brassard à carciel
nous avons été confrontés nous avons été
abandonnés je dirais même avant cette
coupe oup du monde parce que la
responsabilité évidemment appartient aux
instances et à partir du moment où des
décisions ont pas été prises c'était la
libre décision des uns et des autres
jusque au tout début de la compétition
voir pendant la compétition nous avons
été confronté à à à à ces
sujets-là à partir du moment où
il avait été décidé je vous le
rappelle monsieur le Noël legrette et
moi-même monsieur Noël legrette n'était
pas président de la féd moi j'étais pas
sélectionneur la décision d'aller jouer
la Coupe du Monde au Qatar elle a été
prise avant ça remonte à 201
2010 et c'est les semaines les mois
avant où évidemment de par l'importance
de cette compétition il y a des
sujets non sportifs qui viennent et on
demande aux
acteurs de prendre position en ayant ben
là aussi selon euh les pays selon les
cultures des sensibilités euh
différentes à partir du moment où si
c'est décidé parce qu'on est sous le le
les décisions de de de la FIFA quand
vous êtes en Coupe du monde quand vous
êtes en championnat d'Europe il y a un
cahier desesses vous êtes obligé de de
suivre les les
recommandations de la
FIFA si c'est pas le cas après c'est des
décisions qui doivent être prises qui a
une action collective et générale c'est
mieux pour que ça le plus d' d'impact
possible après j'avais pas connaissance
de de de toutes ces éléments je peux
vous assurer que avant une compétition
une au championnat de rotte en ce qui
qui concerne mon domaine j'ai déjà
suffisamment de de choses à m'occuper en
interne et que les journées de 24h des
fois si j'avais quelques heures en plus
je les prendrai bien volontiers et
d'ailleurs en mars 2022 soit 8 mois
avant la coupe du monde de foot au Qatar
Monsieur le Maire a rencontré à
Clairefontaine les joueurs de l'équipe
de France il s'agissait de tourner un
clip contre l'homophobie dans le foot
seul trois joueurs auraient
accepté Jonathan close Jul Kundé et Hugo
Loris les autres joueurs n'ont pas
souhaité participer au clip c'est
archifaud vous dit que trois joueurs
mais vous imaginez c'est toutes les
associations et déjà l'équipe de France
c'est la fédération qui doit décider
c'est pas à titre individuel puisils
viennent ils portent ce maillot là mais
si toutes les associations on devrait
faire des des des clips ou des des
photos mais on peut plus s'entraîner on
peut plus jouer alors vous dites ou
monsieur le maire dit il y a il y a eu
que trois joueurs il a eu trois joueurs
c'est pas que les autres n'ont pas voulu
il y a une liberté mais on les on l'aura
pas interdit aussi mais il aurait dû
peut-être se renseigner peut-être qu'il
y a
d'autres obligations ou d'autres
sollicitations et qu' un moment mais il
y en a trois qui étaient avec lui bon
dans ces trois joueurs il avait quand
même le capitaine de équipe de France
qui est Hugo Loris et les autres joueurs
ils peuvent être investis sur d'autres
associations non pas qui sont contre il
y en a pas un joueur qui va vous dire
moi l'obophobie j'en ai rien à faire ou
quoi que ce soit après c'est une
interprétation aussi je je peux
comprendre la position de de de Monsieur
le Maire d'autant plus que moi j'y avais
participé et je l'ai fait ce qui veut
pas dire que je vais chaque année à
chaque euh événement où je dois être là
merci de votre réponse et de la nuance
que vous y apportter
merci alors peut-être pour en
finir je vais pas vous donner mon
téléphone parceutement pour avoir des
SMS aussi par rapport à nos obligations
et les va se faire passer pour ce
qu'nait pas mais j'ai été joueur
aujourd'hui les joueurs évidemment ils
ont rôle sociétal mais si vous savez le
nombre de sollicitations qu'ils ont que
ça soit pour les les associations bien
évidemment et heureusement qu'elles y
sont et toutes on mérite d'être défendu
mais à un moment on peut pas on peut pas
toujours faire plaisir à tout le monde
je me permets juste je fais très court
vous prenez l'exemple il en a eu trois
il en a eu que trois c'est comme quand
je fais un entraînement à Clairefontaine
qui est ouvert c'est limité
évidemment on peut pas recevoir ils sont
500 600 personnes ben si vous allez vous
allez toujours trouver une personne qui
est venu et qui a pas pu avoir la
signature ou l'autographe de de Kyan
Mbappé c'est scandaleux mais oui mais
Kyan il y a d'autres joueurs autrement
on y passe 5 he on y passe une
demi-heure mais on a d'autres
obligations aussi alors dans ce casage
on fait rien on s'enferme on ouvre mais
si on écoute que le la la ou l'individu
qui est pas content et c'est souvent le
cas on accorde beaucoup plus d'écoute et
d'importance c'est impossible de
satisfaire tout le monde voilà j'arrête
là juste peut-être pour terminer sur
cette ce ce tournage de de clip parce
que je sais pas si vous avez eu
l'occasion ou pas de voir l'audition
d'ailleurs de Monsieur le Maire qu'on
qu'on a entendu ici puisque il a
qualifié les propos du gooris de
surréaliste et très surprenant ce qui
aurait poussé la FFF à ne pas diffuser
le CL clip selon Monsieur le Maire Hugo
Loris aurait répondu que certaines
insultes homophobes répandu dans les
tribunes appartenaient au langage du
foot avez-vous eu connaissance de ces
propos comment les avez-vous accueillis
et est-ce que finalement ce justement ce
clip n'a pas été diffusé
justement du tout sincèrement j'ai pas
le contenu des je gère
pas cette cette partie là le pourquoi du
comment donc et je veux pas fuir votre
votre question
euh je connais bien euh euh Hugo Loris
euh avec euh euh évidemment ses qualités
ses énormes qualités de gardien de but
et l'humain qu'il est avec une famille
une belle famille avec des valeurs et
euh voilà après euh je sais pas ce qu'il
a pu dire c'est toujours ce qu'on vous
rapporte euh forcément euh comme je vous
l'ai dit sur l'une des des premières
réponses
juste voilà je vais juste vous préciser
c'est alors pour le coup c'est pas enfin
c'est ce qu'on a entendu ici en audition
de la part de Monsieur le Maire sous
serment donc c'est pour ça qu'on se on
vous on vous pose la question c'est
voilà c'est pas des des c'est pas ce
qu'on nous rapporte de l'extérieur
peut-être que lui il pense moi je vous
dis des choses sèement je suis par là
pour euh pour pour pour pour mentir
qu'il ait eu si vous dit ça est-ce que
ça s'est passé je peux pas vous le dire
c'est c'est c'est pas de mon ressort et
j'ai pas le le le le le contenu de de de
son intervention euh euh et qu'il avait
participé et bon vous me citez les les
les les trois noms j'aurais été
incapable vous me le demander avant
j'aurais été incapable de vous dire les
trois qui étaient euh qui étaient
concernés ça fait partie j'ai j'ai une
personne et plusieurs personnees et dans
l'entourage et les salariés de la
Fédération mis à part le staff qui est
au quotidien en stage avec moi il y a
évidemment un staff élargi euh qui est
là et au niveau marketing et autres on
est sollicité par énormément de
d'associations des choix sont faits là
aussi peut-être injuste critiquable
pourquoi cette association pourquoi pas
celle-là des enfants ils sont invités
pourquoi euh c'est cette école plutôt
que
celle-là nous ils sont là on est content
on peut leur donner le le sourire on
essaie de faire les choses du mieux
possible justement pour
euh cette cette image que l'on doit
donner à la à la jeune génération mais
avec aussi euh des impères ils ont le
droit à l'erreur et vous allez peut-être
m'en ressortir un moment pourquoi oui
alors il s'excuse c'est la moindre des
choses je fais en sorte après de pouvoir
en discuter avec eux c'est pour ça entre
il y a une grande moi je fais une grande
différence entre vouloir être et tout
faire pour être de bons exemples et être
exemplaire moi le terme exemplaire je
ne je peux pas l'utiliser dans mon
vocabulaire parce que quelqu'un qui est
exemplaire et qui fait tout parfaitement
et qui a pas fait la moindre erreur dans
sa vie si vous en connaissez une
personne vous me la présentez mais
forcément ils peuvent avoir des
attitudes faire des erreurs euh et sans
pour autant être des de mauvaises
personnes
oui alors euh je on entend tout à fait
l'objectif de cette commission d'enquête
c'est un d'identifier les
dysfonctionnements sur les sur les
différents sujets qu'on a pu aborder
donc les VSS le racisme les
discriminations l'homophobie et
l'objectif est bien sûr de voir comment
est-ce qu'on peut travailler avec le
mouvement sportif dans son ensemble pour
remédier à ce qui se passe et c'est vrai
que sur la question du racisme et de
l'homophobie le foot est
particulièrement touché alors aussi
parce que vous avez plus de 2 millions
de licenciés ce qu'on entend donc
forcément ça a un effet grossissant mais
c'est particulièrement concerné donc
donc l'objectif c'est de trouver des
solutions pour voilà pour avancer alors
est-ce que c'est des sanctions plus
sévères est-ce que c'est la prévention
très en amont est-ce que c'est des temps
d'échange avec les joueurs avec les
associations de supporters voilà c'est
tout ça en fait que nous on essaie de
travailler pour pouvoir avancer
là-dessus c'est pas enfin je je le
reprécise très bien je mets pas en doute
votre travail a certainement besoin de
tout ça de la prévention de de de
certainement des
sanctions plus importantes est-ce qu'il
y a une participation
qui peut venir
aussi des des des acteurs que sont les
les sportifs que le football je saurais
pas vous affirmer aujourd'hui que il y a
plus de de de de ça dans le football que
évidemment la seule chose et c'est la
réalité quand il arrive quelque chose
dans le football tout le monde est au
courant tout le monde en parle plus
est-ce qu'il y en a plus ou moins dans
d'autres disciplines sportives je sais
pas et je suis pas convaincu qu'il y en
a mais évidemment le football de par le
nombre de licenciés là vous vous prenez
des ce qui est
arrivé à Marseille c'est un dimanche
soir c'est le match phare télévisé tout
le monde l'attend parce que ces deux
deux grands clubs français évidemment
sil y a un impact qui est une résonance
médiatique et dans dans tout le pays
plus les images qui sont diffusées bah
oui oui ça c'est c'est que ça prend
beaucoup de place et je dis pas trop de
place mais ça prend beaucoup de place
est-ce que ça prend la même place et
c'est pas par jalousie dans d'autres
discipline
euh je pense pas alors que certainement
il y a autant de de problème que il peut
en avoir dans le
football une petite dernière question de
Monsieur Stéphan bchou merci Madame la
prés oui j'ai bien vu votre message je
faire très court je vais faire très
court et j'ai deux questions très direct
et très rapide la première en septembre
2020 je crois que c'est septembre Noël
Legret déclare qu'il n'y a pas ou peu de
racisme dans le football je voulais
savoir comment avait réagi à ce momentl
sélectionneur d'ID des champs je dis
bien le sélectionneur moi j'ai bien
entendu tout à l'heure qu'il avait une
étanchéité complète en tous les cas une
étanchéité entre le sportif et vous nous
avez expliqué donc je vais pas revenir
sur ce que vous nous avez dit mais je
voulais avoir
votre ouis je
va ou c'est juste présidente qui décide
un peu de fonctionnement mais on peut
faire comme ça moi jeok ok ok on y
va pardon je vous l'ai dit à tort ou à
raison et je l'applique encore
aujourd'hui et je lui ai dit clairement
lorsquil était il a été officialisé
Monsieur Philippe Bialot en tant que que
président par principe quand le
président s'exprime je n'ai pas à
commenter ce qu'il dit donc euh après je
peux avoir mon propre avis mais en tant
que sélectionneur c'est mon patron j'ai
pas commenté ce que peut dire euh mon
paton maintenant vous me posez la
question est-ce que euh il y a du
racisme dans le football je vais vous
répondre ce que j'ai un peu répondu
avant pourquoi il y en aurait pas je
vais pas vous l'affirmer aujourd'hui
puisque le le sport comme je vous l'ai
dit
c'est on y retrouve tout ce qu'on peut
retrouver dans euh dans la société donc
euh euh évidemment que il y en a trop
certainement trop ne serait-ce qu'un
incident c'est un incident de de trop
mais par principe je n'ai pas à à à
commenter les sorties médiatiques de mon
supérieur hiérarchique parce que c'est
pas j'estime que c'est c'est pas c'est
pas mon rôle
ok euh bien pris je vous poser aussi
cette question parce que tout à l'heure
vous avez dit
que vous vous vous concentriez à juste
titre sur le sportif encore une fois
bravo pour tous les résultats que vous
avez obtenu et que je pense moi que les
déclarations de ce type peuvent
évidemment avoir un impact sur les
performances sportives de ceux qui ont
été concernés par ce type d'acte voilà
pour le commentaire et ma deuxième
question je vous la pose je vous la pose
très rapidement parce que je l'avais
posé à un de vos prédécesseur qui a
aussi qui est un glorieux vainqueur de
la Coupe du Monde de 98 contenu de tout
tout ce dont on vient de parler et de
des sujets dont s'est emparé la
commission d'enquête si demain Didier
Deschamps est sélectionneur de pardon
est président de la Fédération Française
de Football si toutefois vous le
deveniez quels seraient les axes
d'amélioration à apporter pour que ces
sujets dont on parle et bien à terme on
n en parle plus
merci je peux pas vous répondre parce
que je le saaai pas si vous me demander
non mais c'est pas une réponse de de
circonstances moi voilà j'ai j'ai j'ai
cette fonction je suis épanoui parce que
j'ai eu le l'opportunité de faire de ma
passion mon métier j'estime j'ai jamais
pensé que c'était un travail mais avoir
une un rôle autre que celui qui est
proche du terrain d'être président et
d'avoir excusez-moi l'expression même
sil est de circonstances ici avoir un
rôle quand même politique c'est pas du
tout dans mes envies mais désir et ma
compétence mais évidemment et et c'est
pas je vous dis pas ça par rapport à la
relation que j'ai pu avoir et que malgré
tout même si les moins fréquentes j'ai
toujours avec mon ex-président monsieur
leet il y a beaucoup de choses qui ont
qui ont été faites pour le football
amateur est-ce qu'on peut en faire plus
oui le président Philippe Dialo avec le
Comex et il vous l'a présenté le plan
sociétal euh on peut toujours faire plus
mais là aussi c'est pareil par rapport
au football amateur il y a beaucoup de
choses qui ontp parce que pour moi le
football amateur il est essentiel si
vous avez pas le football amateur vous
avez pas le football professionnel s'il
y en a un qui a besoin de l'autre c'est
le football professionnel qui a besoin
du football amateur il y a des sommes
colossales qui sont attribuées est-ce
que c'est
suffisant certainement pas il faudra
encore encore plus on peut toujours
améliorer mais je je peux pas euh euh
enfin je peux pas je voudrais pas
entendre que rien n'a été fait il y a
des choses qui ont été faite peut-être
mal faite qui aurait pu être fait
différemment mais c'est le devoir la la
Fédération França de de football avac le
nombre de de de de de licenciés qu'elle
a tous les clubs dans les districts et
dans les ligues a une responsabilité
importante évidemment la locomotive ben
c'est les sélections nationales et
l'équipe de France
à qu'elle soit masculine ou féminine
d'ailleurs mais un rôle aussi par
rapport aux différents
sujets de la
société ce sont voilà moi j'ai pas cette
capacité aujourd'hui je pense pas que je
l'aurai plus demain ou après-demain
d'avoir un rôle à jouer parce que
j'estime que voilà j'ai pas de c'est pas
quelque chose qui me qui m'attire et
j'ai je pense pas avoir non plus la
compétence pour faire ça merci Monsieur
Deschamp merci à vous merci de votre
présence à nos côtés c'est dommage qu'on
nit pas eu la possibilité de prolonger
certainement une demi-heure une heure de
plus parce que je vous sentais bien
chaud pour répondre à toutes nos
questions bien parties et je vous trouve
de plus en plus à l'aise parmi nous ah
je suis à l'aise donc j'espère vous
garderez un bon souvenir de cette
audition à l'occasion de cette
commission d'enquête si si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à inviter toutes les
personnes présentes au prochain match de
l'équipe de France on se fera un plaisir
de venir vous rejoindre là il faut
passer par mon Président ça sera un
grand plaisir en tout cas de vous
accompagner sur un prochain match voilà
merci à vous bon retour et nous allons
changé de sport puisque nous avons passé
au rugby c'est très bien je vous
remercie aussi me rappellerai comme si
j'étais jamais venu dans ce contexte là
donc je suis pas contexte habituel mais
et bon bon travail à vous pour arriver à
des conclusions qui j'espère amèneront
des améliorations dans les diff domaines
donc vous avez à vous occuper merci en
tout cas merci